So this is data from Bolivia came out the end of last year and it's from the
year 2003.
Demographic data is always delayed because it takes a long time to collect it
and analyze it and so forth.
And this is
a family standard thing that's happening.
This is various year bunches.
They take these surveys every five years.
This is from a thing called the demographic and health surveys,
which are done basically in every developing country of the world by their own
statistical service.
Every country has a fairly decent census and statistical service and they go and
ask,
uh,
either all the women,
if it's a census year or a subset of the women,
uh,
if it's not a census year and ask all kinds of questions,
some of which you will see.
The first thing of course is how many children do you have?
And they use,
when they started these kinds of surveys,
they used to ask men and they'd get a number,
the husband,
then they'd ask the wife,
get a different number.
And when they checked it turns out the woman who was right and the man had no
clue.
And Vena will tell you maybe some stories about,
it's not even a simple question even to the woman,
how many children have have you had.
Um,
uh,
but uh,
in a,
in a lot of ways men's data was unreliable and in the early days they really
were lynched in getting a real grounded,
they didn't know how many people that were in the world,
what the fragility rates were,
how fast population was growing.
So just to get the basic ideas,
women were asked and from that data on,
men have somewhat been excluded from the data collection.
So a lot of what we know,
in fact almost all of what we know is,
is,
is about when,
but nowadays it's changing.
Last number of years people realize it takes two to tango and men are starting
to come more into the picture anyway here by 19 this is,
so this five year age group and this is the total fertility rate.
And in 1965 and 70 and the years they were having six roughly 6.6 children.
Then gradually every five year increments it came down until the most recent
number is 3.8 children now.
And keep that 3.8 number in mind cause we want to compare that to some other
things.
And uh,
you probably know a little about Bolivia.
It's totally Catholic,
it's quite poor,
it's mostly guys agricultural.
It's not very urbanized.
Education is at a fairly low level.
And the status of women there is not really wonderful.
So with all those indicate what they call socio social indicators,
what would you think about the fertility desires of women in Bolivia high,
low,
high,
all of those are sort of standard classical factors that would make you think
that they want a lot of children.
But when you look at the actual data,
it's rather moderate.
It's uh,
it's still very high by our standards of,
of one or two children,
but still a,
and it's still important for the world because at 3.8,
uh,
you don't double the population almost every,
not quite double it.
Every generation.
So this is quite high,
but it's nothing like a six and a seven child thing or in the past,
you know,
the traditional number of seven or eight or maybe nine children per woman.
So,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's a,
it's a situation of moderate,
uh,
fertility.
Now what the next kind of set of questions is,
well this is the number of children you're having.
How many do you want?
And they ask,
this is asked,
it's a very tricky kind of question as you,
you'll probably hear.
So there's a lot of different ways of spinning,
uh,
this question.
So the first is the ask you,
uh,
did you want your last child?
And that has a whole complicated set of answers and just look out here for the,
for the total numbers that,
did you want the child at the time that you had it?
Well,
38% of women said,
yes,
I wanted it when I had it,
but not wanted it all somewhat larger.
40% of women didn't want it at all.
That's a surprising split.
And then in between is another 20% of women who gave a more ambiguous answer.
Well,
I didn't really want the child right then,
but I probably would have wanted a child in the future.
And there's a lot of guesswork on the part of the respondent in that,
but what their future desires will be.
And as you know,
humans change their mind every five minutes on important topics.
But that's in a very interesting statistic that there's more children unwanted
than are wanted.
And uh,
that's somewhere in,
in between.
Um,
now this probably a lot of bias in this data.
This is not considered wonderful data because you're asking a woman who's just
had a child or fairly recently had a child.
Did you want that child?
What's the bias
to say yes?
I mean,
it's very,
you have to really not like not like that child in order to say,
Oh yeah,
I had him,
but I didn't want them.
You know,
it happens and you see that at 40% of women do say that,
but this is,
data is probably biased to put more kids in this category.
Then what the woman really feels,
although again,
uh,
intentions are,
are very changeable and attitudes toward other people,
husbands,
children,
you know,
one minute you love them,
next minute you hate them and so forth.
So that's problematic.
Uh,
the data there.
So,
oh,
so one way of getting around that particular problem is to ask him,
do you want another child in the future?
That's,
that's more volitional.
That's not saying I did something wrong or if something that I didn't want.
And so here's that,
uh,
set of data and all this from the same demographic and health survey.
And again,
it's sort of what you would expect.
This is women who don't want,
want to stop childbearing,
don't want any more children.
If they've had no children already,
very smooth,
very few of them don't,
don't want any children's six,
six and a half percent.
And they've had one child,
30 already,
30% say one child's enough.
I'm ready to stop.
If they had two children,
you're up to two thirds of the women.
Now say,
that's enough for me.
I want to stop.
And when you get to three,
you're almost at the maximum and then foreign above here into the 90 to 91,
92%.
So you'll notice it's kind of interesting that it rises and then it stays flat.
So there's about 8% of women who no matter how many children they have,
they always say,
no,
I want more.
I don't want to stop.
So this is what we call very traditional women,
uh,
that as many as God gives me.
Uh,
here,
here comes,
uh,
in,
in one version of it,
but it's 8%.
It's a very small number of women who don't seem to have an idea that of some
number at which they want to stop or some of them they've already had,
whether they want to now,
now stop.
Okay,
so now you can,
you can ask another kind of question.
Uh,
you say this is called an an ideal number of children.
And you ask a question.
Like,
if you could go back to the beginning before you had any children,
how many children would you have wanted as your ideal number?
And you get these kinds of numbers that women who have no children want to have
to point who now have no children asking what they think their ideal was.
They want 2.1 children,
women who already have one children,
2.1 those that have to say 2.4 and then the number goes on up,
including women who have six or more children.
Now it's pretty
clear that one should really expect this kind of thing because the simplest,
most obvious reasons,
women who want more children have more children.
So as you have more children,
that's a sign that you wanted more children and that certainly may be the
biggest factor,
just a very simple kind of thing.
Another factor is women who have had more children are older.
Remember we're talking about a period in history.
I mean this is recent where ideas are changing fertility's changing standards
and norms and personal desires are changing.
So these older women just by the age factor will probably be of a somewhat older
generation and they won't go into.
But this looks at that.
Here's the age of woman.
And again,
how many,
if you went back to the beginning,
how many children would you have liked?
And you get just an age factor would not wildly different from this.
So just generational change,
uh,
is a bigger factor in that then,
you might expect,
and also in this rise is what we've just talked about,
that women already had a bunch of children,
you know,
when they reconstruct back what they used to think or now think that they would
think that,
you know,
again,
well I have three on either happy or whatever they think about it,
it's hard for them to say,
no,
I don't want,
uh,
this many.
So have you noticed anything funny?
Now you think about the number,
these numbers and the number I told you to remember,
no class of woman wants more than 3.3 children.
Most of the women are in the two range and only those that have six and more
children want 3.3 and the same.
If you look it out by age,
no group of women wants more than three.
What did I say about how many?
They're having 3.8.
So,
okay,
this now accords with the other stuff that you've seen,
that women want few,
it looks like women want fewer children,
then they're having,
well this is Bolivia.
Uh,
maybe there's something a little bit special about Bolivia and you always have
to check and see whether you're getting some sort of outlier or is this the
general situation so that you don't have to look at that too closely yet?
Uh,
so one of the,
uh,
an economist at the World Bank I named Lance Pritchard,
did a paper and the first thing he did was collect all that data,
uh,
that from every country in these demographic and health surveys are published.
Uh,
every time a country does its own statistical demographic survey.
And so all of this information is available and now it's computerized and so
forth.
And it's,
there's a uniform as a com,
a group called macro international that sort of helps,
uh,
these various countries design these surveys so that they can be con come
compared to international.
You can get fairly good comparability of the data.
And what he did is of these various ways,
various statistical ways of finding out how many children women want and they
have different numbers.
This is average ideal number of children.
This is desired total fertility rate.
Uh,
and here's the third one.
The wanted total fertility rate and they all correct for different factors in
different ways.
But the only thing I think that you have to sort of notice is that a,
whoops,
that they're all about the same.
No matter how you spin this,
you get a picture that looks something like this.
And uh,
what is it one and TFR in this cases,
how many children does the woman want self report.
This is how many she says she wants.
She wants two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
And this is the total fertility rate.
How many children is she actually having?
Having?
So the countries are luckily all named here.
And you can see a Syria for instance,
the uh,
women want five children and they're having seven point something.
Uh,
children,
uh,
here is pick another in Pakistan,
they want four children,
they're having six children.
And so you can look at that in every country,
uh,
is in there.
And one important thing is how important the desire whatever children want.
That is a very strong correlation between the number of children that you want
and the number of children you actually have aggregated by country.
I mean we're taking a lot of people in lumping them into two numbers.
This number and this number and it's a great variation of course within each
country but that's certainly an important factor.
But the key line cause Pritchard and gathering the state of wanting to make a
different point,
which we're not going to get to today but he left.
It leaves out a really important line here,
which is this line that I've drawn this sin in.
What line is that?
That's the line where as if you want to children,
you have two children.
If you want three children,
you have three children.
If you want nine children,
you have nine children.
So any country that was on that line,
people are having the number of children that they want.
What do you notice about all these countries?
Every single one of them is above the line,
meaning that in every single country they're having more children than they want
what they want.
That's what they have.
They're all above that line of equality.
This is some of the cleanest social science data I've ever seen.
The way they're all one side of a line there,
there follow very nicely the regression line.
This is the regression line that he drew in,
which is just a line,
uh,
that uh,
is closest to all the points together,
a statistical way of making a line as close as possible to all of the points.
So this,
this gap here between what people want if they,
if they got what they wanted and what they're actually having.
It's called unmet need,
very complicated idea,
much argued about and being may or may not discuss it.
But what it tells you is that there's a,
a very noticeable difference between,
uh,
the,
it's describing that difference between the number of young people have and what
they want.
And it's roughly one child per family here.
And this number in principles should be one and a half children.
But there are certain connections actually about one child per family.
The difference between what they have and what they want.
Now,
um,
in the developing world,
this is a little bit old data,
but in the developing world today,
the average fertility rate is about 3.5 in order to come to stable population,
the developing world,
it has to come down to 2.1
but if all the women here and these countries that are reporting what they want,
if they actually had the number of children that they want,
you'd subtract out from the 3.51 child,
you're down to 2.5 and you're actually very close then to replace what's called
replacement level fertility.
This 2.1 children.
And so this difference of what women want and what they have is an extremely
important issue.
And one version of the kind of thing that planned parenthood and other
international and domestic organizations do is help women get to the fertility
that they want as not as pushing them into something,
but uh,
giving them something that they already want.
So,
but this data as in old data brings up a whole bunch of questions.
One,
does this really reflect people's data?
Have we actually have these kinds of questions?
And this kind of cystical analysis really tapped into the real emotions and
feelings of the people.
You always have to question these kinds of survey data.
And you remember that you read this as the readings and Africa,
that when the women were asked how many children do you want?
It was a meaningless question to them.
They said,
whatever Allah says,
whatever God says,
they can't do it.
You're just not in there.
What they,
the technical terms is the calculus of rational choice.
Well,
there's women like that in the survey.
And what number do you put down?
Uh,
uh,
for them.
Um,
uh,
this woman,
as I've said,
is basically is all collected from women.
What about men?
Do men want more children?
Do they want the same?
Do they want less?
Is it women's desires?
Don't matter.
Is it men's desires that,
that,
that really matter?
Um,
why do women up here in,
in Kenya and Molly at this time want so many children?
And have so many children.
Whereas countries you might not think of wildly different.
Trinidad,
Dominican Republic,
uh,
Fiji,
you know,
various other places are way down here.
Why some countries here and some countries,
uh,
they're um,
another thing is that in most of the world,
uh,
people actually know about contraception and here is a date again from the
Bolivian survey,
2003 and [inaudible].
Do they know of method of contraception?
Well,
they know any method.
Yeah.
95% of the women know about contraception.
And even the modern methods which are listed here,
92% of the women they know about it.
And many of the women know about more than one method.
So 80% know about the pill and other 80%,
the IUD and other 80%.
The injectables that means is in a lot of overlap between these.
They not,
they don't know what method they know.
Two,
three male condom.
They know about female sterilization,
they know about and so,
so on.
This is lactational Amen area,
which is the traditional method that we've talked about of of spacing births.
And half the women know that if you breastfeed,
uh,
you'll prolong the interval between your births.
Not only do they know about the method,
but they've used the method.
77% of women have tried something.
A fair amount of that is 20 20% of these women are using only traditional
methods,
uh,
which is includes rhythm type methods and but still 57% have actually used a
modern method currently using drops down.
They've tried it and for some reason they've stopped.
Um,
so one is this medical problem that the dominant reason why women say they're
not using contraception.
So you've seen the data,
they want to stop child bearing.
So overwhelming.
You saw like,
uh,
I believe you have,
what was the final number?
I don't even know.
I pointed that out.
70%.
I think.
Let's go back here.
Trying to find,
oh thank you.
Remember that came from something like 70% of the women say,
I don't want any more children ever.
I want to just plain old stop.
And then if you add in those that are not sure about the future,
but they say,
well at least not in the next two years and then beyond two years,
I don't know.
So you had at least another 10% something like 80% of women want some kind of
protection,
either one mostly stop totally or uh,
at least for the next two years.
And you can even go down.
This is again,
older data from Bolivia.
That's one of my favorite places.
I was sent some good times there.
Um,
if you just take teenagers age 15 to 19,
already,
about 40% of them say I ever had all the children I want for the whole rest of
my life.
And the average age of that sample is 17 years old.
So you have this huge number of women who don't want,
want to stop child bearing.
And yet if you look from the demographic and health surveys at the contraceptive
prevalence,
like in Bolivia,
again at the time of the Robey article that you're have read last night are
going to read the women who want protection either either.
Our Bat,
we're about 80%.
And the women that were using pressure was like 12%.
And you ask them why.
And uh,
largely,
uh,
and especially more and more recently it's medical reasons.
There's first of all at campaign by,
by conservative and especially religious people in places like Kenya to,
uh,
they're opposed to the use of contraception and they really blow up,
medical problems.
So the people are getting very poor information on it.
Now,
here's,
here's an example.
So one of the undergraduates that took this course some years back,
uh,
very energetic young lady and she was got interested in this stuff.
And so I arranged for her to go to Kenya to answer exactly this,
this question,
why is it that women,
and you'll hear a little later,
why is it that women who say they don't want any children,
they're living in Nairobi and there's plenty of contraceptives available in
Nairobi and you can get them more or less free,
a small costs and they're not using it.
Then they get pregnant and they can't have that baby.
They don't want the baby.
So they go to some Bush doctors and you know,
it's illegal in most of Africa,
sub Saharan Africa,
all of Africa,
abortion is illegal,
but here they are pregnant.
So they go to some horrible doctor and the death rate is very,
very high.
So here's women who don't want children,
uh,
don't use contraception even though it's available to them.
And yet when they get pregnant,
they're willing to undergo an operation,
a very crude Optima,
illegal operation by an untrained practitioner,
uh,
that will,
that will lead to a very high rate of death.
And their Wello well aware of that.
They,
everybody knows somebody who's died from a botched abortion.
And you've read some of that in the European,
the,
in the era in America and Europe when that was a common.
So she went there and it turns out that women are very much influenced by rumors
what they hear because their education is not really their,
their thing.
And so she called this student,
does he yell?
Undergraduate,
uh,
collected these rumors.
And one of the rumors,
one of the most extreme rumor was,
well mostly in African,
I think you read this,
uh,
the,
you know,
people that haven't been the university don't distinguish between stomach and
uterus.
It's all one big cavity.
There was that in one of your readings,
you think it was in anyway,
it doesn't matter.
It's all one thing there.
So now you take a pill and they know something about pills,
penicillin,
everything.
But every day for the rest of my life,
why do I have to keep taking this pill?
Why didn't I take the pill and that,
that,
that settles the issue.
Well,
they figure I get pregnant and the,
and the,
the fetus starts to grow inside me.
Well,
what does the pill do?
The pillow goes down and dissolves.
They have some idea that it's wet,
so that dissolve and then reforms over the face and starts coding it.
But every day they know the fetus is getting bigger.
So you need to take another pill to add to the code of it.
And at the end,
what you grow and what you get is a mummy.
You get a fetus that can be fully grown or newly flew coated with white stuff
like an egg and that's what you deliver.
Well if you believe something like that,
you're not going to go anywhere near pills.
Right.
And some of these similar kinds of stories happen with everything else.
This young lady herself got the,
the five little silastic implants in her arm when she came back,
she was very,
she got it in Kenya.
One could,
she wanted it and to do you want to show the women's,
see it's not dangerous.
I,
I'm even doing it myself,
but that's irrelevant.
Okay.
So the one thing is the,
the any no clue about medical stuff,
physiology,
digestion,
anatomy inside,
you know,
huge numbers of women don't have any clue about this,
but this girl,
uh,
did a very clever thing.
You know,
she was a Yaley and she then asked the women,
you know,
Kenyan women are not any stupider than anybody else.
They're,
they're smart women.
He said,
do you believe such a rumor?
Because they were just reporting it as a rumor and they,
women that were of course,
very skeptical of this.
Well,
I've heard that and you know,
it's true or not and they were properly skeptical of it.
So she collected this whole range of rumors and she found it.
She asked which ones do you believe more than others?
And she's sort of could get a ranking on it.
And then she asked all kinds of questions and it turned out that it was very
simple that they believed something depending on how many times they had heard
it in terms of this particular room was not one of the most prevalent.
Some other rumors were equally not true.
But if you hear it a lot,
then you believe it because they don't have a sense of
expertise,
scientific competency,
any of that sort of stuff.
And uh,
on,
uh,
a sociologist at Penn,
Susan Watkins,
so I may have mentioned before and certainly we'll mention again who works in,
in Kenya and the low region,
different,
not in Nairobi,
a different region.
Uh,
she,
uh,
attended a lecture where a local woman speaking local dialect had gone to
Nairobi and gotten trained nurse type.
She wasn't a trained,
uh,
an official nurse working in that kind of assignment once an Arab and got
trained to be uh,
uh,
reproductive health educator.
So she comes back and just having some sort of a white coat or a uniform or a
blouse or something and she gives a lecture to the women with,
um,
they have these model bay models of pregnancy models of internal anatomy slides.
Very nice.
And she,
she was good at it and the women are absolutely wrapped,
you know,
they're listening to every word,
but as they left the room,
they started sort of staring at each other.
What are we going to make out of this?
And outside there was a woman's scrubbing the floor Washer woman there and these
women just dove onto the washer woman and said,
she telling me what she telling is true.
Is this good for us as she,
the are kind of women that the and,
and,
and really ask the washroom and all kinds of questions about this information.
Which of Washington had no technical expertise.
The Iba idea being that they don't have this sense of that knowledge comes from
some sort of expertise that more knowledge comes from someone like me is a more
important variable than that.
You've been to Nairobi and gotten some kind of training and the washer woman
they perceived was closer to them than the woman who had gotten some education
even though it was a local,
a person from that,
that local community.
So it's a very complicated issue and the big battle is in people thinking about
this and trying to do something that is sort of what she said.
How much of this difference in how much of of the people in general having more
public,
how much of it is that?
Is that there's something wrong with this data?
They really do want a lot of children and many of the,
you know,
many countries were up there and they wanted five,
six,
seven,
eight children.
And how much of it is,
uh,
they don't have access.
Now acts,
if I have to,
I guess I have to stop access to hear you,
but you're not leaving.
Access doesn't mean just handing out condoms.
So there's a famous,
I'll tell this last story,
you know,
shut off.
So there's a famous story of the passes around family planning circles about
someone going into an African village and finding in front of each hot a stick.
And the stick was an unrolled condom.
And of the one that was very strange.
And so they went and asked what this is.
Oh,
we had a family planning worker come here and they showed us how to prevent
pregnancy and they had the stick in and they showed us how to unroll it.
And they did that.
And I've heard this kind of story any number of times and I tossed it off,
you know,
it's something like I had the doubts,
well more doubts.
I just tossed the story off.
Then I'm inclined tower.
And I came out one night,
I work late and then the forestry was having a party and,
and some,
uh,
of the,
of the graduate students were out back smoking or chatting or something.
So I chatted him up and one of them had been in an,
uh,
a part of South Africa called [inaudible].
And what she told me,
she went into this village and what did she see?
It wasn't,
it was cucumbers and holding people had cucumbers with condoms and rolled on.
So this is a student who's here at Yale right now that's solace with her own
eyes.
So it's another one of these amazing stories.
That's true.
And it gives you sort of at least an anecdotal hint into what's going on.
Uh,
be scratching beneath her.
There's this data.
Okay,
see you next week.